hi I'm Walter banana AK and this is top
five here we countdown the best and
worst performances of our most beloved
actors guys I've seen some stuff some
bad stuff today we're counting down the
top five worst performances of Adam
Sandler may God have mercy on your soul
there's no way around saying it Adam
Sandler has made quite a few stinkers in
his long career recently he took his
talents over to Netflix for movies like
the ridiculous 6 and the do-over even
before that Adams work with slowly
declining in terms of critical acclaim
and audience support he's still very
popular and as we've seen a very very
talented guy
however the choices he's made for quite
a few years now have left something to
be desired he's got a reputation for
being one of the nicest guys in
Hollywood and I'm sure that's true but
we're here to judge the worst today that
top 5 worst performances of Adam Sandler
number 5 Donny Berger in that's my boy
this movie had some people intrigued
since it had Sandler going into r-rated
territory but the movie itself was not
well received and Sandler's Donny Berger
is a big reason why while in high school
Donny Berger begins a sexual
relationship with and later impregnates
his teacher miss mcgarricle when the
relationship is made public she's thrown
in jail leaving custody of their son to
Donny's father until Donny turns 18 the
boy Todd leave Donny as soon as legally
possible years later Todd is days away
from getting married when Donny shows
back up in his life what Todd doesn't
know is that Donny owes 43 thousand
dollars in back taxes the father and son
share weekend that brings up bad
memories and creates new one do you like
Boston accent because I've got the
performance for you comedy is about
taking risks and someone is bound to be
offended by something but this whole
movie is trying to be as offensive as
possible to as many things as possible
and not in a smart or clever way
think about this premise if the genders
were reversed yeah not good sandler
himself is very reliant on his
funny accent and creates a character
that tries to have some depth when
reminiscing with his son but that isn't
nearly enough to excuse the Sheep
feeling performance in committee I used
to put it on the meat in my hand he
would cheer you up all the time when you
were sad oh boy your share young man I'm
your best friend even Al Amin Amin man
while there is a moment or two of
genuine laughter and a miniscule dose of
character attention that's my boy is a
perfect example of a Sandler misstep in
recent years and it only gets worse from
here
I don't know image to be a Chicago bike
in fucking handless pretty good version
number four Niki in Little Nicky Sandler
tries his hand at playing the son of
Beelzebub
maybe he enjoyed this performance when
the devil refuses to retire two out of
his three sons revolt by heading to
earth to disrupt the balance between
good and evil the devil's third son
Nicky is the only one who can stop his
brothers and restore that balance
however Nicky isn't much of a demon and
doesn't exactly fit in in hell once on
earth with the help of a few friends he
discovers things about himself that give
him the confidence to take on his
brothers like a lot of his movies from
this era Little Nicky isn't all bad it's
a very strange story that does work in a
few spots Sandler's choices for Nicky
are just a little too over the top of
notches while the character is
definitely likable hearing that voice
over and over again gets old very fast
yeah I used to talk normal - but that
was before my brother Kathy has hit me
in the face with a shovel oh that looks
like a taste great
is annoying yet do I get on your nerves
I'm just a good guy in a bad situation
am i annoying yet am i annoying you yet
by the way I'm not sure if this was a
planned role for Quentin Tarantino or he
just wandered on the set and they record
what he did why do you talk to me with
your dusted your evil it's stinking up
on street the end is near we all gonna
die
other than the bad choices he made here
I actually don't hate little Nicky it's
just passable and it brings back
heavenly chubs can't be too hard on it
number three Zohan and you don't mess
with the Zohan another bad accent
another bad performance Israeli
commandos Oh Han is tired of the
fighting in his country and decides to
fake his own death he then leaves for
New York City to fulfill his dream of
cutting hair for a living once in the
Big Apple his signature cutting salaries
him a good reputation from a local
female population however his past
slowly begins to catch up with him and
this time his new friends may possibly
be caught in the crossfire you don't
mess with the Zohan look off to me from
the first trailer so I avoided it upon
watching it for this list I'm glad I did
I will give it this Michael buffer is a
big bad guy here and that is so far out
of left field that I commend them for
even thinking of that just wow
good on you if you bitches can't get
those people out I will find other
people who will get the job done however
win it all right Sandler is playing an
eccentric badass who loved women and
loved cutting hair there's not much more
to oh man the usual Sandler plot points
eventually show up you don't know my
feminie on maybe you do what does this
mean
just leave
please it can't be once again a few
chuckles are hidden in there but overall
it's not much fun also there's a really
bad mock Rakhi montage in this you know
just to give me more incentive to not
like it do yourself a favor and don't
mess with the Zohan number two schecky
moskowitz in going overboard calling
this a movie is being generous schecky
is an aspiring stand-up comedian who
works as a waiter on a cruise ship the
ship's own resident comedian Vicky
diamond isn't too kind of Shecky and
when he traps himself in a bathroom the
whole ship sinks him dead this leads to
Shecky taking over his spot as ship
comedian the problem is he's just not
very funny
so also Paulie from rocky sends two
terrorists to kill an Australian model
or something I'll let Adam explain this
one to you well what you're about to see
is a fictitious loosely thrown together
story about a sea cruise waiter me right
here who dreams of becoming a stand-up
comedian this story is based entirely
around the fact that we had access to
this nice big boat here and a lot of
good-looking women this came out in 1989
the for Sandler even made it on Saturday
Night Live it's basically a prototype
for what his movies became later except
without any of the good this struck some
sort of presence this is an alum budget
flick not a low-budget flick no budget
they also have the audacity to show
another Rocky parody this time when
Pauling is actually in the movie to
double the disrespect
I want any tea chats I want any getting
below the waist
I want any food or drink on the maps
it's a noodle and may the best man win
let's go other names who show up here
are Billy Zane Billy Bob Thornton Milton
Berle for some reason and the biggest
name of the law Lars from heavyweight
this was Sandler's feature film debut
and it wasn't pretty
he's pretty bad in this and it seems
like he's apologizing for the movie in
the middle of it I'm just going to be
checking schmuck way to the rest of my
life I'll never touch a woman again I
got a touch of one I just want to grab a
question I know it because and that's
not good for my career either you know
that and I know that so this was really
bad and I'm not sure if they were lazy
or just didn't know what they were doing
in any case it's one of Sandler's worst
[Music]
and the number one worst Adam Sandler
performance is jack and jill sadelstein
in Jack and Jill
after Walter saw this film he slowly
began to lose the ability to speak here
are some of his pre-recorded comments
jack and jill sadelstein are fraternal
twins who live on opposite coasts when
Jill visits Jack and his family in Los
Angeles Jack wants his annoying sister
gone as quickly as possible
however Hollywood legend Al Pacino
becomes very attracted to Jill who Jack
is trying to land for a Dunkin Donuts
commercial after learning this Jack
forces Jill to stay longer so he can
secure the deal with Pacino this must
never be seen by anyone if you didn't
like all the close-ups we can do we can
this is not the final cut it is no doubt
we tweekin all copies destroy them I'm
not even sure what else I can say about
this movie and performance that hasn't
already been said we share mom's room we
will remove eight in the movie funny
people there was a sequence where they
show clips from bad comedy movies the
character played by Sandler in that film
did this movie is worse than any of
those trailers in all honesty the
clock's ticking
so if dinner works we gotta get to work
I'm kidding you I just said that because
I'm very nervous right now and I'm just
keep talking so much my mouth is moving
I don't even realize how much it's
moving it
I'm not even curious at Scotney as Jill
Sandler is trying his absolute best to
be as obnoxious as possible mission
accomplished where were you so I'm just
waiting forever filled this place is
creeping me out
why so many bags in the Knicks traveling
with you one is with it mom always said
it's better to have it and not need it
than to need it and not have it a lot of
stars make appearances in the film
including Johnny Depp and Al Pacino as
themselves the latter being a main focus
of the movie hell you broke my heart
[Music]
also what the hell is this diving into
the deep layers of the Jack character he
dresses up as his sister near the end of
the film that's pretty much when my
brain began to stop functioning properly
Adam Sandler is not a bad actor he's a
multi-talented performer who quite
honestly is spinning his wheels with
these bad movies he can be so great and
it's a real shame how his talents seem
to be so wasted with these movies here's
to hoping Adam once again starts showing
us all why he's as good as we know he
can be I want to hear what you guys
think what is your least favorite Adam
Sandler movie and or performance well
you want me to cover next on the show
leave a comment and let me know if you
haven't already make sure you go back
and check out my top 5 best Adam Sandler
performances also make sure you check
out awesome comics from yesterday where
we're asking the questions are the Star
Wars prequels really that bad follow me
on twitter at awesome underscore walter
to take part in more polls about who i
may cover next on the show come back
next week for a brand new top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you